pancartas con las consignas fue el
ejército o nos faltan 43 cientos de
estudiantes y familiares de los
estudiantes desaparecidos en Ayotzinapa
realizaron un plantón frente a una base
militar de México que terminó
enfrentamientos entre la policía y los
manifestantes mientras las madres cuyos
hijos siguen desaparecidos cargaban
carteles con sus rostros es preocupante
decir que hasta el día de hoy no sabemos
nada de nuestros hijos y eso es que nos
duele de lo más profundo de nuestro
corazón no saber a dónde está nuestros
hijos y es por eso que estamos aquí este
dejando familia nuestros hogares dejando
todo nuestro trabajo por venir aquí por
manifestarnos que queremos la verdad A
dónde está nuestros hijos no podemos
permitir más injusticias basta de
impunidad los manifestantes derribaron
las vallas se intentaron Acceder al
campo militar número uno de la capital
dejando al menos un uniformado herido
el 26 de septiembre se cumplen ocho años
de la tragedia motivo por el que
activistas y familiares están saliendo a
las calles para exigir respuestas a las
autoridades después de que la comisión
para la verdad señalar al mes pasado que
se trata de un crimen de estado con
autoridades de todos los niveles y el
mismo ejército implicados
[Música]
contra los demás elementos del ejército
hasta el momento se han dictado órdenes
de detención contra más de 80
sospechosos entre ellos militares
policías y miembros de carteles este
viernes el presidente Andrés Manuel
López Obrador prometió que estos
crímenes no quedarán impunes